KAL MAINNE KAHA THA
WEALTH HUSTLE SE NAHIN
BANTI. AAJ MAIN VAH
EK FRAMEWORK BREAK DOWN
KAROONGA JO MONEY, MINDSET,
RELATIONSHIPS, HABITS SAB PAR
APPLY HOTA HAI.
AND TRUST ME THIS
IS A GAME CHANGER.
TO DEKH AATH SAAL,
DEKH AATH SAAL I
SPENT FIGURING OUT KI
KO KAISE EFFORTLESSLY WEALTH
BUILD KAR LETE HAIN
JAB BAAKI SAB LOG
GRIND KARTE RAHTE HAIN.
LIKE ISKA ANSWER HAI.
IT'S NOT HARD TO
ARCHITECTURE AND I CALL
IT FINANCIAL INTELLIGENCE. ISKE
PAANCH MAIN COMPONENTS HAIN.
1 ASSETS JO NIND
MEIN B POCKET MEIN
VALUE DAALTE HAIN. SECOND
LIABILITIES HO SOTE VAH
TUMHAARI JEB KHAALI KAR
RAHE HO. 3 INCOME
WHAT COMES IN, FOURTH
EXPENSES WHAT GOES OUT
AND FIFTH CASH FLOW.
INCOME AUR EXPENSES KE
BEACH KA GAYA. AB
VAH BAAT JO KI
KOI FINANCIAL GURU NAHIN
BATAATA KI YAH SAME
ARCHITECTURE LIFE KE HAR
AREA MEIN APPLY HOTA
HAI. LIKE THINK ABOUT
IT. LIKE HAVE A
PRODUCTIVE ROUTINE ACID HAI.
DOOM SCROLLING LIABILITY LIKE
PEOPLE SUPPORTIVE NETWORK ACID
HAI TOXIC DOST LIABILITY
HAI THOUGHTS GROWTH MINDSET
ACID HAI. LOG KYA
KAHENGE LIABILITY HAI SAME
PATTERNS EVERYWHERE LIKE MAJORITY
LOG EK HUGE MISTAKE
KAR RAHE HAIN VO
SIRPH MONEY KO OPTIMIZE
KAR RAHE HAIN SALARY
BADHAO KHARCHE KAM KARO
BUT BOSS TUMHAARE CHHAH
DOMAINS IGNORE HO RAHE
HAIN. REAL WEALTH TAB
BANTI HAI JAB TUM
SAAT AUR KO SIMULTANEOUSLY
OPTIMIZE KAR RAHE HO
FORMULA SIMPLE HAI.
POSITIVE CHAAHE VAH PAISA
HO JAMA KARO. AB
SEE EK TYPICAL MEDICAL
UPBRINGING MEIN LIKE HAMEN
KYA SIKHAAYA JAATA HAI
KI REPUTATION LOG KYA
KAHENGE LIKE YAH SAB
ZAROOR I GET IT
BUT FINANCIAL INTELLIGENCE SE
LIKE YAH EXTERNAL VALIDATION
TUMHEN KYA RETURNS DE
RAHA HAI KYA MAINTENANCE
MAANG RAHA HAI? AGAR
YAH KAUN SA TENANCY
YAH PRESSURE HIGH HAI
TO VAH ACID NAHIN
HAI EK LIABILITY HAI
AND IT'S RAINING YOUR
ENERGY WHILE YOU ARE
SLEEPING. SO KAL MAIN
POORA CHITHA KHOL DOONGA
REGARDING MY PERSONAL ASS
LIABILITY FOR CASH FLOW.
CROSS ALL 7 DOMAINS
LIKE FOLLOWER I AM
NOT SURE ARCHITECTURE VARNA
MAT KARO LIKE THE
FRAMEWORKS HUA KI TO
BE SEE YA.